[Applause]
all right we head over to the Senate
side of the capital complex where just
yesterday FBI director Chris r ray he
was grilled over how the FBI has been
politicized and the doj weaponized and
his bureau weaponized take a look I
think the Department of Justice has been
profoundly politicized under attorney
general Merrick Garland and I think the
FBI has as
well and
unfortunately I think you've been
unwilling to stand up to senior career
officials on the FBI who's allowed the
FBI to be politicized have a
responsibility to the
FBI not to allow it to be a partisan
tool a a a and a partisan weapon the
testimony and by the way the FBI's done
nothing and I have not and I will not
have you opened an investigation into
whether the Attorney General lied under
oath to Congress and whether the
Attorney General obstructed Justice I'm
not going to go down that road here I I
know you're not that's the point nobody
thinks you've opened an in investigation
because you're not willing to all right
joining us now with more Texas Senator
Ted Cruz is with US senator thank
you just to dovetail off our last
segment you asked Ry you know he
wouldn't answer your question if the FBI
tried to ascertain Joe and Hunter
Biden's location when that WhatsApp
message that I I read in in my opening
monologue was uh sent um also you rip
Ray for not answering questions about
the hunter investigation
and you ripped him for how the bureau
has been politicized and weaponized um
what is your take is this FBI director
involved in a cover up for the bidens is
this a dual justice system I thought
Lady Justice was to be
blind well I think she's blind deaf and
crippled right now and and I think it is
a sad situation um this Department of
Justice this FBI is the most political
it is the most partisan it is the most
weaponized we've ever seen as you noted
in your opening monologue you played
that WhatsApp where Hunter says I'm
sitting next to my father and he
threatens a Chinese Communist with
retribution from Daddy unless he sends
millions of dollars now Gary shapley one
of the two IRS whistleblowers said the
investigators had a very obvious way to
check it they wanted the GPS data was
Hunter sitting next to Joe Biden you
both of them have phones you can
ascertain where they were the instant
that text message was sent Gary shapley
said the Biden doj blocked that
investigation said you're not allowed to
get Hunter or Joe Biden's GPS data
you're not allowed to inquire no
questions about the big guy so I asked
Chris Ray did the FBI try to get the GPS
data to determine whether this was in
fact a bribery Shakedown Chris Ray's
answer was well I'm not going to talk to
you about an open investigation it's the
biggest lie it's the biggest shell game
they claim it's an open investigation
but they're not investigating anything
refuse to investigate anything and when
there's accountability look we've got
major whistleblowers saying the attorney
general has committed multiple felonies
and the Attorney General stonewalls the
FBI stonewalls and Chris Ray's answers
yesterday were disgraceful he believes
he owes no accountability to Congress
and no accountability to the American
people and and one of the things I
shared with him as I travel the country
I am regularly approached by FBI agents
who are horrified by what's happening in
their agency they're honorable men and
women they want to they want to defend
the rule of law they want to catch bad
guys and instead the political
leadership at doj is turning them into a
coverup Patrol for the Biden White House
I want to get your reaction Senator if I
can and this uh these comments by uh by
Christopher Ray talking about how he's
never seen the terror threat on every
level as bad as it is now saying you
know blinking lights are everywhere yeah
now this why has he been why has his
silence been deafening when it came to
Joe Biden's 8 plus million illegal
immigrants and now we know where they're
coming from Iran Syria Egypt Afghanistan
China Russia tens and tens of thousands
uh can you did you ever get an answer
out of him now he's finally warning us
after all these people are here unvetted
that the terror threat has never been
greater in history what is your reaction
to that to me that's a dereliction of
Duty I know he was busy looking at you
know into moms and dads at Schoolboard
meetings yeah and going after pro-life
protesters people that were doing it
peacefully and I know he was you know
really looking hard at that Hunter Biden
laptop and warning big Tech why hasn't
he been dealing with that threat issue
listen the FBI has stonewalled on these
questions for a very long time and it
was you know about a year ago that Chris
Ray was going before Congress saying the
biggest threat we have is crazy white
nationalist come on it's not like
there's a a surge of Nazis running
around they're idiots and bigots but but
you want to know what the biggest threat
is it's Hamas terrorists and Hezbollah
terrorists coming across our Southern
border seeking to carry out a terror
attack and and I got to tell you when I
was down at the border just a few weeks
ago our border patrol agents are very
worried about it we've got a war in
Israel and and and when I see Chris Ray
finally the FBI finally acknowledging
that Terror threat what that tells me
Sean is they are seeing so much evidence
I think we're at a greater risk for a
major terror attack now than we've been
any time since September 11th and I got
to tell you I did a classified briefing
today from the administration the number
of specialin aliens from dangerous
terrorist countries has skyrocketed
under Joe Biden and they still refuse to
secure the border and if anything happen
s to any American he will have blood on
his hands we have been warning
absolutely right by the way
congratulations your book by the way
we'll put it up it is called unwoke how
to defeat cultural Marxism in America
Senator Ted Cruz thank you hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else